the numbers are a lot lower than during
the early days of the uprising that
began almost two months ago but protests
against the governing elite persist in
some areas of Lebanon especially after
it was announced that formal
parliamentary consultations to appoint a
prime minister to head a new government
will be held on Monday ever since the
revolution started we've been calling
for an end to corruption everyone in the
ruling class has been accused of
corruption and they're now working on
forming a new government that includes
the same political parties which means
they're not listening to our demands
samer ha teba successful businessmen
with no political experience is likely
to be nominated for prime minister his
ties with the political elite has
enraged protesters his name emerged
after caretaker Prime Minister sandal
Hariri withdrew his candidacy his
condition to head a government
independent of political parties was
rejected by the governing Alliance
mr. haughty has been the second choice
for the political powers namely
Hezbollah and their allies they would
they would have preferred Hariri to have
this new government because they need
this national unity government they need
the Sunni cover actually to face the
international pressure it's not just
protesters who are against fatigues
nomination the sun-li religious
establishment hasn't endorsed him the
post of Prime Minister is reserved for a
Sunday Muslim in Lebanon's sectarian
power-sharing system Sunni politicians
including former prime ministers are
accusing the president and his allies of
violating the Constitution they say the
president should have called for binding
parliamentary consultations before
holding back door meetings to reach a
deal on the next prime minister and the
makeup of his government this they
explained weakens the position of the
head of government whose jurisdiction is
to choose his ministers and present the
lineup to Parliament for approval
whether Monday's meeting will go ahead
isn't certain the governing Alliance is
led by the Iranian
back hezbollah group which is a target
of US sanctions it knows a government
that doesn't have the support of all
sects and this seen hezbollah LED or
controlled is unlikely to receive the
international financial assistance that
is badly needed to revive the economy
Zahra qadir al Jazeera Sidon south
Lebanon